Hello everybody welcome back to the
channel for another video I personally
am feeling like crap this morning and
I'm extremely hungover and this is
because my body is more poorly
maintained than a legacy code base I
don't think I'm gonna have any topic
specific jokes this morning simply
because the 911 risk to reward joke
ratio is just not there but uh yeah
without further Ado let's do another
possibly the last low level design
episode in this series which is going to
be the airport control tower alrighty so
let's design an air traffic control
system so basically just to get some
background on what this is in case
you're not entirely sure the entire
point of an air traffic Tower is
basically just to sit there at the
airport and tell planes when they're
able to do things like Land from the
airspace go to the taxi go to a specific
gate and even when they're able to
depart so just to go ahead and actually
write out the requirements of this
problem we're basically going to have
the following a plane is going to
basically enter the airspace of our air
traffic control tower and from there you
need permission from the tower to go
ahead and land at the arrival plane taxi
from the arrival plane taxi you need to
be able to be assigned a gate assuming
there are even vacant Gates and then
when you're at a gate and you want to
depart you again need permission to go
to the departing plane taxi and then
from there you need permission to go
ahead and depart so that's all good and
dandy however there's also some
additional complexity to this problem
added by the fact that it's possible
that things like the taxis may be
completely full and a plane cannot yet
enter them even possibly from the
airspace and the same goes for Gates
there may be no Gates left at a specific
airport and as a result they would have
to wait in the arrival taxi for a bit
before they can actually go to a
specific gate
okay so let's think conceptually about
how we want to go ahead and model a
problem like this well basically the way
that I've chosen to kind of think about
it and that's how I'm going to pitch it
to you guys is that our air traffic
control center is kind of like a server
right and all of our planes are like
different clients the clients are going
ahead and making requests to the server
and in turn the server is going to go
ahead and get back to them saying here's
what you need to do now so in this case
the things that the air traffic control
center would do is basically receive a
response from the client or the client
saying I'm ready to move on to the next
stage of this Pipeline and the server
would basically say Okay however it's
not actually that simple as we know in a
client server architecture at least a
traditional rest API the client will go
ahead and ask the server for a response
and the server will instantly send one
back however in this case that may not
always be possible the reason for that
is that we know that there's not always
going to be space right there for
example you know a plane might have just
landed and now it's in the arrival taxi
and it may want to go to a gate however
there may be no available so as a result
of there being no Gates available what
the server or in this case our Traffic
Control Center might have to do is take
that request from a plan saying I'm
ready to kind of go on to the next round
hold on to it and only once there's
actually going to be uh you know some
amount of Readiness or you know some
empty space for the plane to actually
move on to in the pipeline can the
server or air traffic control center
respond back to the plane so we kind of
need this concept of real-time push as
well our basically our traffic center
has to be able to receive messages from
Planes and also independently send them
out not only when prompted
okay so with all of those things
considered let's start thinking about
some classes that we want to look at
um obviously one class that's going to
help a lot to have is an airplane class
the reason for this is that there is
state that an airplane has to follow and
also some functionality that they have
to be able to perform so we know
basically that we have our airplane
class and that can have something like a
plane ID this is useful just for the you
know purpose of bookkeeping right in our
Traffic Control Center we want to keep
some amount of state with regards to an
airplane we also have our current
location this is useful as kind of
keeping track of status right so if
we're in the departing taxi if we're at
a specific gate and you know right now I
have this as a string in reality you
would probably want this as an enum or
if you're using something like ocam I'll
do some sort of nice pattern matching to
kind of go against that status and then
you also have this Boolean ready which
truthfully I think I kind of cut out
later in the design so it's not overly
necessary but it's useful if you just
want to keep track of whether the
airplane is ready to move on to the next
stage of the pipeline then finally we
have one method called advanced which is
effectively just going to take the plane
and change it from its current state to
the next state in the pipeline I'm not
going to implement this but the general
gist is you know if you call Advance and
the current state is airspace for
example then it would go and change the
current state to a arrival taxi and then
of course the corresponding Getters and
Center methods
okay so now let's start to actually
think about our control tower and the
interface that we can go ahead and
Implement for that as far as I'm
concerned there are really only two main
methods that we have to go ahead and
implement but let's go ahead and think
about what those will do so basically
the first is going to be actually
acknowledging that a plane is ready to
move on to the next step and we can just
take in a plane ID and that way you know
we can keep track of all the planes that
we care about and so you know when we
acknowledge that a plane is ready that's
great but it doesn't necessarily mean
that that plan is going to move on to
the next step it may be ready to move on
to the next step right so now we have to
consider it for potentially moving on to
the next step however it may be the case
that you know just due to the fact that
there are a lot of other planes in the
airport we can't go ahead and move it on
just yet and so for that reason now we
have the second method called send
Advanced message which we can go ahead
and send back to a specific plane via a
plane ID I'm assuming this is basically
just going to be like the radio and then
once a plan is going to receive that
message internally it can call its own
Advanced method to go on to the next
stage of the pipeline I also have an
optional payload just because you know
think of this as like a request where if
I were to tell a specific plane okay
you're going to gate G4 I would need to
put that in the payload
okay so let's think about some data
structures that we actually need to be
able to make use of if we're going to
implement this problem like I mentioned
one of the requirements of this problem
is that we kind of have to buffer
requests when there's no space for them
right so if I'm a plane and I'm in the
airspace but I'm not able to land yet we
know that basically once a plane reaches
out to the Tower and says I'm ready to
land if it can't land yet it should
probably go in some sort of queue right
that's the only way to make things Fair
because otherwise a specific plan could
be starved it would never be able to
land if we were to use some other
heuristic of choosing which plan is next
to land and if a certain plan was in the
airspace for too long and unable to land
well obviously it's just going to run
out of gas and crash so it's very
important that we do a kind of first
come first serve queue in order to make
sure that we're fairly choosing the next
plane to move on to the next step of the
pipeline when planes do in fact say that
they're ready if there is you know kind
of no space available
so here are some places where we should
be using cues to make sure that we're
choosing fairly which plane moves on
when there is a lack of space the
airspace the arrival taxi the actual
planes themselves and Gates when they
say they want to go to the departing
taxi and then actually we don't need a
queue for the departing taxi because the
second a plane in the departing taxi
says I'm ready to go well it should just
go ahead and go and that kind of Begins
the entire process of the pipeline where
once a plane is on the departing taxi
and it says I'm ready to depart it's
going to instantly go and kind of leave
the airspace and then now we can kind of
start moving the other planes through
the rest of this pipeline if that makes
sense
okay so let's actually think about how
we might run the controller class I'm
basically just assuming that uh every
kind of instance of the plan is you know
is able to kind of communicate with this
controller you know perhaps we pass it
in Via like a dependency injection or
something like that but just generally
all we're doing is handling all the
plane requests to move forward the
controller is going to be acknowledging
the played ready request and then within
that big knowledge plain ready request
method you're going to see that I will
end up actually calling that advanced
method to tell planes to move forward
um another kind of concern to quickly
touch upon is actually going to be
multi-threading here
um so as you can see I've kind of have a
single threaded Loop in the previous
slide for the controller to kind of go
through all the requests but then the
reality is if we're kind of modeling our
airport controller like a server it
means that in reality we're probably
going to be receiving a lot of
concurrent requests and when you have
concurrency means we have to think about
things like locking and our data
structure is making sure that they're
thread safe so we don't have race
conditions so the example I provided
is what if there are two planes in the
airspace and they both want to be able
to land but there's not enough space for
both of them to land we need to make
sure that um basically our controller is
not reading the like the current buffer
for uh the arrival taxi and saying okay
both of you are good to land because if
so they're going to both land at the
same time there's not going to be space
for both of them and then they're going
to crash so that would be an example of
a race Condition it's very important
that we would use something like locking
in order to ensure that there wouldn't
be uh basically race conditions and
issues within our airport system however
at the same time I think that
multi-threading is also kind of beyond
the scope of this problem but perhaps
some interviewers might want you to
touch upon it
okay so this is going to be a long
method and so I ended up writing it out
in English just so I could kind of fit
it all on one slide but let's go ahead
and run through the process of actually
acknowledging a plain ready request
you're going to see that within this
method I call Advanced plain ID a lot
and keep in mind that that itself is
also a complicated method which I'll
touch upon in future sides so basically
we have this plain ID that we're taking
in as parameter and the first thing that
I'm going to do is assume that our
airport traffic controller uses some
sort of hashmap to actually get the
corresponding plane object from that
plane ID
after this we can check basically the
plan status and then from there decide
what action to take so for example if
the plane is in the departing taxi like
I said if you're ready to depart and
you're in the departing taxi and then
you want to depart you can just go ahead
and do that there's no issues there you
don't have to wait upon anyone else so
basically from there we would just say
okay there's now an additional spot in
the departing taxi and we can call
Advance for that plan if the plane is at
a gate we first need to check if there
are spots available in the departing
taxi so that it can move forward and if
there are basically we have to say okay
now there's one less spot in the
departing taxi we have to basically take
the gate that the plane used to be at
and put it back into a list of available
gates to choose for future planes and
then now we can call Advance on the
plane and then otherwise now we have an
issue where we have to basically enqueue
this plane in a queue of planes that
want to go from gates to the departing
taxi so that's easy enough we can do
that we plus we place it in that queue
we don't call Advanced plan it's a very
similar thinking process for when the
plane is in the arriving taxi right
if there are open Gates we can assign
one of the gates to it we can basically
say that gate is no longer available and
we can also say there's now an
additional spot in the arrival taxi then
finally we can also call Advance with
that plane and pass in the name of the
gate to go to otherwise now we have an
issue again there's no space we're going
to have to actually enqueue this plane
in the arrival taxi to gate q and then
finally if the plane is in the airspace
we have to basically check if there's
spots in the arrival taxi if there are
then we can go ahead and say okay now
there's one less spot in the arrival
taxi because this plane just landed to
it we can call Advance on the plane but
if there are no spots available in the
arrival taxi then we have to put the
plan in a queue of planes trying to go
from the airspace to the arrival taxi so
from this point on I basically showed
you guys how to enqueue all the planes
or when to call Advance but we also have
to think about well if there are
basically planes in the queue how do
they get out of the queue and this is
kind of where this Advanced plan ID
method comes in
so basically the way that I've chosen to
implement this is kind of with recursive
logic right so every single time you
call Advance on a specific plane what
I'm going to do is check the status of
the plane that you're advancing right so
let's say that you're calling advance on
a plane that was in the departing taxi
okay so now we know there's going to be
an additional spot in the departing taxi
so what I'm going to do in the actual
Advanced method is now check if there's
any elements in that queue trying to go
to the departing taxi and if there are
I'm going to call Advance on that first
element of the queue so now you kind of
see this recursive functionality and
then I'll say okay well
I just called Advance on an element from
basically the gates uh or a plane that
was at the gates and I just called
Advance on that so now within our
function again Advanced I'm going to say
okay well this plan was at the gate so
now let's check for elements trying to
get to the gates from the arrival taxi
and then in turn I'll call Advance again
so you can see that recursively we're
kind of going backwards through that
pipeline from the planes that are
departing all the way through and as a
result of this Advance is going to allow
us to eventually move all of our planes
up every single time that a plane is
Advanced we know that we're going to be
reaching out to the actual plane object
itself and the plane object can move
from one stage to the next and change
its status internally
okay guys so that's kind of all uh there
is for this video it's actually not
overly complicated but it did actually
take me a while to kind of get to the
solution so it's definitely not
something that's super easy to just kind
of code up on the spot but at the same
time you know if this kind of client
server architecture models stays strong
in your head and you see that it's not
just an instant request and response but
sometimes you have to respond later then
hopefully this video should make a
decent amount of sense
all right guys well I hope you enjoyed
this video
um it's been fun doing these low-level
designs and I'd probably have a couple
more before I call it a day with these
and then I'll go back to the drawing
board on more types of videos to make
but as long as you guys are continuing
to enjoy them I will continue doing them
and uh yeah have a great weekend